欢迎收听股,我是孟公,本期节目由比若我赞助
现在国际乳清原料的价格越来越贵
选错品牌就像是挑错选股
成本都出去了,获利却没跟上来
比若我专注做蛋白补充这一块
不卖保健概念,不搞复杂配方
就是把蛋白质的来源成分比例
这些基本的东西做好,让你补得到位
如果说有乳糖不耐,喝乳清容易脏气
或是吃全素的人
植物蛋白是你的最佳优质解
完整六种植物蛋白的来源
大豆 豌豆 糙米都在里面
一份20克以上的蛋白质 膳食纤维 维生素 矿物质一起补充
没有以上困扰的人也可以考虑浓缩乳清
是平正高中棒球队的指定补给品
口味有12种
很多人从苹果牛奶口味入坑
YouTube JoeMan也特别喜欢喝这一个
喝起来真的有点像小时候喝金苹果的味道
不知道从哪开始就可以选择这一个
最后这一个最屌
零酒精的乳清仿啤酒
有在健身的人最怕聚餐
桌上一堆啤酒喝下去爆热量
这款比一般啤酒或是快乐肥宅水热量少一半
每罐还能够补充10克的蛋白质
不用为了聚餐破功
还能够喝到一样的气泡爽感
我觉得这个非常懂健身仔的痛点
有需要的可以在网址直接搜寻
berule
记得结账的时候输入我的折扣码
全管满2000现折100元
现在乳清涨很凶
这折扣很珍贵
或直接到我的影片下方的资讯栏
提供给所有有需要的朋友们
好那我真的觉得时间的推进之后
会让一个人慢慢的长大
像這一波行情當然是殺得非常嚴重
像截至今天的話
我大概已經跌回去5月初左右的一個禁止了
那Maximum Drawdown大概是Draw
可能大概25-28%
還沒有細算
但大概就是回這樣子
那以這樣子的成績
在我們的同業之中
因為我們不可能每個都去問大家狀況怎麼樣
可是有分享的
就像有些它最高的時候
它今年可能是賺到好幾倍
有些很誇張的6-8倍的
那他們可能大概Drawdown就是一個50幾%左右
那這算合理
因為它賺的時候非常快
它是下來回多一點是正常的
像我自己的話
最高大概是到200多%左右
所以在今年這個行情
目前回20幾30%覺得還OK
但是其實很害怕的是
就是你不知道這邊是不是就是一個終點
還是說會再繼續下去
而且我的20幾%其實已經是悲傷
因為前面已經是把
絕大多數的部位都換去聖奎谷
就是我把台積電系成為聖奎谷
反正就是多君最後堡壘
大家視後看也發現說台積電真的跌最少
那其他中小跌要爆掉
所以我已經有一大堆的台積電加台紙
那還是可以回到這樣子
所以又代表說這個行情真的不是人玩的真的是非常恐怖其實倒一下這個節股眼理論上比較合理的操作是你應該要去買那些掉到地上便宜的東西
可是掉到地上便宜的東西
因為真的沙太深了
心態整個壞掉
還記得大概一兩個禮拜前的節目
我會跟大家分享說
如果你今天掉到季線下面的
我可能就不想看你了
但如果現在你不看季線下面的東西
你已經沒有東西可以看了
就幾乎全部東西都已經跌破季線了
所以就變成是我覺得非常棘手的狀態
但心情上算是調適的還OK
不知道是不是因為紅眼露比有一個非常成功的debut
同時也非常感謝這麼多人的支持
我也看到很多實況主有去播
雖然有些實況主
我就想說你至少把新手教學看完
如果你有看新手教學
你就不會玩得這麼痛苦嗎
從頭到尾都在平A
不知道在幹嘛
但還是非常感謝他也是有協助去幫忙開箱
我們並沒有付什麼業配費用
去請這些實況主幫忙打
可是大家非常自發的
蠻多人都有去玩這款遊戲
非常感謝各路的支持
就是像他可能開始把一些重心
放在一些比較偏向生活層面的東西
隨著自己的個性也變得稍微的收斂一點
沒有這麼急躁
你說像他這回廠痛不痛
可是就沒有像以前可能會
開始有一些吃不飽睡不好
也不是說吃不飽
就是說你連飯都吃不下
還是吃不下
再來可能在晚上的時候
甚至有時候會一直爬起來
然後去看說現在美國的夜盤跌多少
在過去的幾年已經顯著的去改掉這些
我認為其實算是壞習慣
簡單講就是說如果你會影響到你的生活的話
就代表你的部位可能是下的太大
是這樣
這個部位下的太大其實它是蠻因而異的
有些人的部位下的大是可能兩三倍槓桿以上
以我自己來說
我發現我可能只要打到大概1.8到兩倍以上
我就會覺得我的壓力很大
所以其實我的槓桿都壓在大概1.3倍以下
甚至是更少
所以以這樣的狀態去面對這樣子的盤勢
就是痛歸痛
可是並沒有到會覺得要受到毀滅的感覺
那現在也開始有一些朋友會問說
這一波跟去年3月的關稅戰比起來
是不是可能更加的嚴重
只能夠說真的沒用
去年的3月是真的比較恐怖
這邊稍微再講鼓一下
老聽眾一定都是陪著我們一起經歷過
各式各樣的修正
其實這一波也算是那種很嚴重的股災了
就是可以在歷史上留名的
也有可能我們取名就是說
2026的中小或AI科技大屠殺
2025就是關稅屠殺
2024就是ODM的屠殺
就是每年其實都會有一個那種主題
把它殺到爆掉
其實在去年3、4月的那一波真的比較恐怖
因為你現在回頭看都很簡單
所以我就說很多人他居然說他去使用那種槓桿的某些產品然後他們回測就是去找可能過往跌比較兇的那個時間點然後來測說他當時扛不扛得下去我只能夠說你這樣去測
你會有非常大的一個偏差
為什麼
因為其實在當下你是看不到終點的
就像現在的這樣的一個行情
大家感受一下
你是不是不知道說
你看今天又一堆東西鎖跌停
會不會明天又繼續鎖
那一種你看不到希望的感覺
才是真的會擊潰大家的東西
所以其實你現在回頭看
你會覺得說
去年的關稅的時間
不過大概回可能滿多東西是鎖三根
甚至再多一點
但其實滿多大型股
可能鎖一兩根之後就回穩了
所以看起來還好
沒有其實當下是非常非常恐怖的
而且它是在放完廉價之後
直接給你炸
所以整個流動性是抽乾的一個狀況之下
像我自己都跑去掉錢
我都到處去找一些銀行
然後去開一些額度
雖然我自己沒有立刻那種斷頭的風險
可是你當下為什麼這樣做
因為你不知道
會不會三根跌停之後
變六根跌停 九根跌停
所以那是當下很恐怖的點在這裡
當時甚至讓我犯下了一個
我後來把引以為恥的事情
因為當時我是已經開始有去籌足一些
簡單講說一直以來
我都有去做一些小型的投資
這些投資其實大家講好之後
就是時間到會計可能談好
我們就會把錢打進去
可是我竟然去問一些
我們要合組的公司的人說
有沒有可能我們先稍微暫緩
公司先暫緩
因為現在整個流動性卡住
我不知道各個股票會鎖跌停
鎖到什麼時候
所以其實經過那次事件之後
對我來說很大的一個教訓就是
我對槓桿這個東西更加的小心
其實當時大家也知道說
有蠻多跑去跳樓
甚至有上新聞之類的
我們自己身邊同意的是比較少聽到
但是有一些投資公司
就知道說在三四月那波之後
就一蹶不振了
就再也沒有起來過
因為它一次回檔就回太多
我要回到它再也站不起來
所以從那之後自己就非常的小心
像這一波為什麼會說
沒有像三四月那麼恐怖
即便你看說絕對的跌幅
可能蠻多是超越
因為這一波
其實後來我也是聽身邊那些大哥
我有猜意識到
對耶 為什麼你看那個大盤
為什麼會一直殺不出量
以前這樣子殺早就殺出量了
你知道像貴買現在跌20幾%了
快往30%去了
你知道2022其實全年它最高到最低
也就大概是30幾%左右
所以我們等於是花一個月的時間
把中小的2022跌完
差不多這種感覺
所以理論上早就該殺出量了
理論上早就該很多人斷頭了
但是其實你看看自己的部位
如果說你不是可能過去一兩個月才加入
你是可能年初或是去年就加入的
其實吉他多數人都還是賺錢
其實講白一點這樣
0050都還是正報酬
然後再來就是你看這些疊超級兇的中小就是各個族群其實它基本上全部都已經爆炸了你去看他們可能去對應它過往的一個價格就覺得說今天這個價格你去往前對
你就會發現說它差不多就是跌到4-5月左右的一個價格
所以如果你不是在可能5-6-7月
然後瘋狂的加碼買一堆在山頂變頭重腳輕的話
其實大家好像真的都沒有那種斷頭的壓力
就是很痛而已
就是你本來以為你賺很多錢然後回途
就類似我現在或是我們身邊很多人的一個感受
也因為說可能大家都只是回土的狀況之下
就變成一直殺不出量
就是大家在互相虐待
因為以前我們的慣例就是知道說
當你今天跌很多
突然間爆量
一大堆成交量跑出來
就是有人認輸了
不玩了一般就要給反彈
像其實今天台股的尾盤就有點像
就要跌到39000多點
然後接著幹回去4萬尾盤
其實在這個尾盤
我們身邊蠻多人都在頂說
那些跌了聽的股票會不會全部都打開
如果打開的話就代表說就大起繼續
這個大奇奇奇奇可能過去
每年也會發生個一兩次
可是其實蠻多沒有打開
就代表就鎖死了
所以應該要等到明天
就是有些人再被斷頭
然後才看有沒有機會再一次打開來
可是如果說你今天是用
像身邊大哥提醒我這個
你其實這個股票
就只是兩個多月沒漲
大家是不是被寵壞了嗎
就是我們在那邊抱怨
大家在那邊哀啦
然後大哥就跑出來說
你這個是被寵壞掉了
就是過去的股票
可能兩三個月沒有漲回檔
那都很正常
可能過去大家都是太習慣說
每個月都賺錢
像四五月
我們自己的節目也是
我不會說是膨脹
可是你事後回聽會發現說
那時候真的過得太逍遙
就怎麼可能你每天開盤
可以跑去打球
你都不用看盤
然後東西就一直漲
其實現在回頭看就會知道說
那時候其實就要有一些警覺
好在就是我們自己期待
所以去做一些調節
就是可能今天你有跌破一些
關鍵的均線
就是去做一個停損或是停利
take profit之類的
但是因為我自己的習慣是
我不喜歡去搞空手這一招
所以我就把東西怎樣
就塞進去那種台積或什麼台紙
所以是跟著大家一起吃回檔
只是理論上在這種時間點
就是因為我們現在看市場上
滿地都是真的是一大堆10倍股
再來就是一些IC design
可能以前是那種
trade到30 40倍去的
現在竟然在20幾倍
就是傻小
就是好便宜喔
真的很便宜
可是已經有點不太敢買了
因為其實在過去的一兩禮拜
就已經持續有在買
怎麼樣買
就是把你本來趴在可能TSM
或是你趴在台紫棋的錢拿出來買
像在美股的話就是
你趴在蘋果的錢
你可能就拿出來買東西
只是發現說無底洞
一直買一直跌
所以其實下次有點怕
甚至會覺得說
如果後面再出一個人道走廊
因為前面也先出過第一次人道走廊
然後那次有人道走廊就是
就是把東西我是換進去就盛虧股
就躲到盛虧股裡面去
然後躲到台子旗裡面去
只是第二波我可能就不會這樣子做
我會選擇更保守的一個做法
就是可能如果今天再給我一個反彈的話
給我有機會去調整部位
我可能會再塞更多的東西
跑進去台子旗裡面
或甚至是就考慮會去拿一些現金
因為這個跌幅是非常恐怖的
但其實理論上
我們看到這麼大的一個跌幅
後面應該也會有超大的反彈
只是問題是你有沒有辦法撐到那個反彈
然後就算有這個反彈出現的話
其實蠻高機率
就是他還是不一定會彈回去你加碼的地方
就像說像有些東西
我可能一兩個禮拜前就開始買
像那種你要我怎麼再一個反彈就彈回去
我覺得超難
就是我一定是要再去做一個攤平
或者是說可能就要再去做一個等待
然後才有機會讓它回到那個成本
但一般來講
我們其實不太在意這種沉默成本
就是你已經賠掉的東西
你就是把它當成已經是賠掉
即便它是帳上的未實現
可是因為我們的統整方式是用禁止去算
所以其實對我們來講
就是那已經算是一個沉默成本
現在的關鍵比較像是
要怎麼樣去抓到後面可以回到新高的東西
因為你知道這樣子下來
其實有滿東西應該就是不會回去新高
那只是
我所謂不會回去新高不是說怎麼永遠
就是說可能在短期的波段內
可能大概三個月半年之間不一定會回去了
可是如果今天的市場是沒有死掉的話
假設市場是沒有死掉
後面是繼續創高的話
你知道說指數它一定是會創高
因為指數裡面的components
一定會有東西跑出來帶頭
但是問題是指數裡面的滿東西
可能就不會再上去了
所以比較穩健的方式就是可能
先選擇趴進去指數裡面
或是可能像身邊蠻多朋友
現在都是直接選擇不玩的
不玩最大
我自己目前的初估規劃
是因為我八月多才開始要帶孩子出去
所以可能到八月多也會調整成
現在已經是慢慢往那個方向去
就是可能單一持股就是不會超過10%
然後可能就會打得很散
可能過去會很集中去做一些東西
題材 主流 或者是動能的東西
但後面就會變成是
因為現在可能滿地有那種10倍15倍以下的東西
所以在我們的角度看
我們又可以知道說未來的展望
假設說什麼AI沒有真的把它泡沫的話
在這邊讓大家去死的話
理論上這些東西可能下就是一個
在我們角度是便宜的機會
可是老實講因為它真的太便宜了
便宜到你在懷疑說是不是老闆不在家
還是這東西是不是有炸是不是有毒
所以就不敢去重壓
其實有麻辣東西看人真的非常喜歡
只是心態變成是這樣子
我快速的跟身邊一些朋友討論
我覺得大概是這樣
因為已經是怎麼講
這波是跌到已經沒有那種定海神針的感覺
以前可能還會有一些族群
一些特別強勢的東西撐在那裡
可是這波就是反正全部都下去
就連可能最穩的台積電也下去自然它下的幅度是很少它每天可能就是用3%以內的速度再下去然後別人可能是用跌停或是那種7-8%速度下去只是瞎看起來就會覺得
有點不太樂觀
特別是沒有特別的消息
出來的狀況之下
然後竟然可以跌成這樣
這個是非常傻眼
我們再快速的復盤一下
雖然我們可能沿路就有陪大家聊
只是現在你回頭看他知道
就像油價
大家說可能是因為美意戰爭
又再更加的嚴重
所以跌這個
可是油價後來再掉下來的時候
你看這個盤也沒有反彈
所以我們初步認為說
當然這有可能是其中一個原因
但應該不會是一個主因
那會不會是聯準會搞不好
真的要去做一些升息
然後去跌破大家的眼鏡之類的
以目前的角度來看的話
會認為說機率不大
但如果說他真的這樣子做的話
那其實這波回真的是
把他回太深了
就是有必要嗎
有必要因為一個升息的決定
然後就回成這樣的一個程度嗎
不知道就可能等到今天晚上
FOMC還是明天晚上
反正就是最近要開了嘛
那看他們是怎麼樣做討論
如果說開完之後
不管是開好或是壞
市場就穩住了
那可能就代表說前面可能真的在跌這個
就是市場是很害怕這件事情
然後再來另外一個
屬於我自己會比較擔憂的點
就是其實這一波大家知道說
震災算是在韓國
就是由韓國開始
韓國開始大量的崩跌降槓之後
然後後來就引導到全世界去
雖然覺得說以美國來講
就是美國的SPX還是非常的硬
可是美國的半導體相關
科技相關的也就跟得下去
因為AI相關的東西都掉下去
日本的股票也一堆都得要爛掉
台灣的股票跟AI相關的
或是過往的一些漲價題材的東西
大家都摔要爛掉
我們知道說核心的政央是在韓國這一邊
如果說我們今天去解構韓國的東西的話
當然很大的一部分是你知道說
他們開了超級巨量的槓桿
這個我們在金融恐怖份子那一集
有跟大家稍微聊過
可是如果說我們先把巨量的槓桿
這件事情稍微的把它劃掉
我們就單純去討論
Samsung跟SK Hynix他們的狀況是怎麼樣
為什麼
就是如果你今天是用FOR的PE
或是PBR去看
它其實並不是一個特別貴的東西
它都可以這樣子摔
這個是不是有隱含什麼樣的一個訊息
這個就會讓我會比較稍微的擔心一點
因為其實嚴格上來說
現在在市場上最大的一個共識就是
最缺的東西就是記憶體
這個我相信去問任何一個人
大家都會告訴你一樣的答案
因為不管是產業界或是股票圈的人士
在大家看得到的數字跟一些
Forecast的狀況之下
就知道說反正最缺的東西
就是在記憶體這一邊
那只是最缺的東西
外加可能Future的prospect
就是大家都覺得是蠻好的東西
它都可以殺到這樣的一個層數
是不是有可能隱含的
就像說像過去的半年一年我們蠻常在講一件事情就是現在市場上最便宜的AI股已經變成是台積電跟NVIDIA這個大家應該有印象也不是我的專利其實蠻多人都有發現這件事情就是奇怪了就明明是AI核心的東西
為什麼它會是最便宜的東西
然後反而一些快樂夥伴
他們噴到30-40倍的一個估值
AI核心的東西可能4P
就大概是十幾倍
甚至可能有時候會在震盪之下
你會發現說靠北
那種有破盤價的狀況產生
它可能過往的區間
都不曾經到這麼低的地方
有可能就是說
你把NVIDIA或是TSM
想像成是一個Benchmark
然後過去可能大家的習慣是
因為我們知道說有一堆在三四十倍的東西
所以我們就覺得說
TSM跟NVIDIA是不是低估了
因為相對之下他們是便宜的東西
所以是他們要上來 對吧
但經歷過7月之後
其實其他的態度就會變成說
會不會他們的價格是供訂價
所以如果說在AI裡面
最火最熱的這些公司
不管是Memory或是TSM或是NVIDIA
他們的可能4PR的Ratio
都只能夠在這個位置的話
會不會是其他人其實要熟練下去
就是理論上
當然除非說某一些components
不是說每個東西都一定要比NV
或是台積電便宜啦
不一定是這樣子
因為有些東西可能是
它超大的收回
只有它有某一個關鍵的零件
它營收的增幅超大
那它trade貴一點是合理的
那我們就不去就單一公司去討論
如果說我們今天直接抓一個族群來看的話
如果說我們把各個族群都抓進來的話
然後去考量到像這一波的一個
科技股的大屠殺
就是有可能市場的敘述會改成是
前面大家是認為說台積跟NV太便宜
他們應該上去
然後現在就像說換個視角去看
變成是他們其實是正常的價格
如果他們都還在下殺的話
那是不是其他人要殺到更低的地方
只是當然在過去一陣子
其實我覺得中小已經是很加速在往下面撞了
其實現在真的是
我們自己身邊朋友討論都會嚇到
靠北不是怎樣 AI還好好的
我們看到的Forecast跟產業面都還好好的
可是怎麼會一堆東西已經掉到
你知道10倍股
然後甚至有那種七八倍股出現了
當然如果說歷史有教會我們什麼東西的話
我自己本身在金融海嘯的時候是沒有做股票
可是我們很常會去看那些
我們沒有參與過的市場
然後去了解說
如果你回到當時你會怎麼做
我們會知道說
其實如果真的是有泡泡要破掉
然後真的要出事情的話
其實甚至是5倍股3倍股都會出現
那事後回頭看
也就是可能兩三年之後
你真的發現說他當時是被低估了
就像非常經典的故事在講說
其實Amazon那時候從山頂掉下來
他上跌到90幾%吧
可是Jeff Bezos他寫給股東的信是Ouch 然後提到說其實我們公司都是往更好的方向我也不知道為什麼股價會崩掉九成但我們的各個指標其實是越來越好
如果說歷史有教會我們
就是我們知道說
是有可能在一些極端的狀況之下
就是我們過往去守的一些估值的防線
是有可能有問題的
因為像我自己我家的體感非常
明顯的原因就是因為
在過去一陣子
像我自己開始去賣一些什麼台紙
或是TSM或是蘋果
就是相對穩健的東西
然後去買
可能不管是美國台國的東西
我就自己有設定一個
可能估值的filter
你今天已經掉這個估值一下
我又知道你未來好的
我沒有道理不買你
可是當我買了之後
我又發現說你可以再往下
15% 20%
甚至沒有要停下來
我真的會開始去思考說
會不會我買錯了
會不會是有一些我不知道的東西
那抑或是會不會其實大家的估值
都必須要調到某個位階之下
所以我現在的做法是
我會去思考一個相對負面的劇本
只是我在思考負面劇本的時候
我比較不會做的事情是
就我知道市場上一定有些人會開始說
就是應該要放空啊
就是應該空手
其實我們節目這麼多年來
我們是不太去做這樣的事情
我真的算是每個人選擇啦
你覺得很危險
你覺得要怎麼樣
當然你有自己的一個做法
只是我就會比較傾向是
我今天去買個股的時候會更加小心
甚至是可能在個股這邊
就不會去做太多的琢磨
而是就集中往指數的方向去
因為當今天已經不知道
方向該怎麼開的時候
就特別是可能
像兩個禮拜前的節目
還可以講說那種記憲以下的我不看的
你如果不看寄線以下的東西
你要看殺小
寄線以下的東西幾乎滿地都是
寄線以上的東西反而是極度罕見的
而且現在其實還可以直接點名出來
哪幾支是還在上面
這個感覺就跟我們可能在一兩個禮拜前
在講矽晶圓跟宅板一樣
就是全市場都知道說它是避風港
所以等到後面避風港的資金塞完之後
搞不好它就開始補跌
大家後來就看到那些族群就補跌
其實有可能就是現在還在寄線上的東西
後面又會這樣子
所以就會覺得現在這個盤
有點像是在踩地雷
就是不管你做什麼
都可能給人家幹到
所以可能就是要切換成為
特別是也是在身邊那些朋友
一些前輩的提醒之下就知道
可能就是沒有辦法像過去那樣子搶錢了
就今年可能大家搶錢都搶得很開心
那種各種族群切換切來切去
那基本上都可以賺錢
或者拉回就是無腦買
那現在可能就會稍微的
會把週期看長一點
然後再來就是一定是不要再去使用槓桿
因為要再去使用槓桿的話
你不知道這個波動會多大
就算這邊出一個反彈的話
其實怎麼講
如果這個反彈是在上個禮拜或上上禮拜
我覺得還OK
因為其實上面的均線沒有這麼多
可是現在已經跌這麼深了
然後現在反彈在碰到
那些群線全部都是壓力
就一定會有一堆解套的
或是什麼樣就要把它丟出來
所以我就會覺得
變得比較難搞一點
那抑或是
其實按照過往的經驗
就當一堆東西的型態
都要壞掉之後
它要再繼續重
它可能需要整理一陣子
這個可能在美股跟台股都是這樣
雖然我們想要可能這一集
講比較多那種價格
跟技術面相關的東西
那是我們的輔助
就我們用這個作為一個輔助
只是我覺得是值得參考的
就是如果當今天一堆東西的價格
是已經一次回到太深的話
其實一般來講
要直接V上去的情景會比較難一點
就是越低的越難V上去
它可能會需要一段時間的盤整休息這樣
所以其實雖然目前比起來跟去年3月比
沒有到那麼嚴重
但是我覺得可能會跟去年3月
後來那個recover的狀況有點像
就是它可能給你一個V
然後V上來之後就是要橫一陣子
然後慢慢推
然後慢慢的重振信息
然後大家要找到一個族群
再把它切進去
我覺得有可能是往這個方向去
在這個同時
當然以下的角度來看
可能大家就會覺得說
研究是沒有必要的
其實你做什麼事情都沒有必要
因為反正市場每天就是只會跌
可是像我自己的工作態度
就是我還是會覺得
怎麼說
就是你平常沒有做準備的話
你就只能夠等到後面
假設行情突然間轉好
然後你就蒙著眼睛亂嘴東西
可能也是蠻痛苦的
所以近期還是有去
掃一些市場上的機會
像前面大家在講KIMI K3之亂的時候
我覺得它裡面的一個silver lining
是告訴大家講說
其實這個東西也是著重於Agenti AI的使用
Agenti AI方面
大家都知道CPU是裡面扮演一個非常重要的角色
最近其實也是因為啟發於
我注意到一些臉書的粉專
在討論這件事情
或是說一些新聞的頁面
因為大家在討論這件事情
就讓我去做了一個研究
其實我們過去都知道說
像陳立武跟Suma他們都有提到說
未來你可以期待的是CPU跟GPU
可能會以一個1比1的方式去做呈現
因為在Agenti AI的應用上面
其實他們需要非常多的CPU
當然這裡面一定有一些商業的術語
怎麼說
因為這兩家就是在靠CPU賺錢的
非常明顯是這樣子
大家會說目前NVIDIA也是有靠CPU賺錢
只是Vera就我們了解
它那個Stand alone Rack
就是只有Vera CPU的Rack
目前我們的考察之下
它的客人可能不多
大概只有一兩家廠商有去做使用
所以短期內不會注意到太大的放量
當然像是Janson他也是有提到說
CPU的用量
然後跟趨勢是非常的明顯但是他沒有去丟出可能比較強烈的行銷術語像是陳立五或者是蘇瑪所提到的就是他會往1比1的方向去靠我們在過往的節目上
就是前面CPU之亂的時候
其實有跟大家聊到說
我覺得短期內
你很難看到直接往1比1去靠
因為其實你從一些客觀的數據就知道
就像說你今天去看
NVIDIA的GPE
或者說VR-Rubin
或是最近AMD出的Helios
它的Spec已經開出來給你看了
它就是一個Epic Zen的CPU
然後再配四顆MI Series的GPU
所以它還是1比4
就想說奇怪
你們大家其實都沒有丟出1比1的產品
只有NVIDIA的Vera的CPU Stand-Around Rack
它是完全的純CPU
所以是不是1比1的說法會是有問題的呢
我就很快的去找了一些身邊跟產業圈的人士去做確認
目前所了解到的狀況應該是這樣
其實CPU它不一定會是以AI Server Rack的方式呈現給大家看到
也就是說當然這裡面有很多的討論的空間
像美光最近跟Meta他們發的一個白皮書
就告訴大家說
如果你今天從DRAM要卸載到SSD的話
其實那個速度是慢幾十倍
所以理論上就是DRAM或是說HBM
這類的記憶體的用量
應該還是會比那種存儲的東西
還要再強大非常多
因為你這個料理才越大
你可以做的事情越多
所以如果你想通這個道理
就會了解到說
如果今天你不是把CPU
直接像可能Headless這樣子
或是VeaRubin
它本身就整個CPU在AI伺服器裡面的話
它速度一定會有所延遲
如果說我今天我需要去用到這些CPU
我是要連到外面的
General Purpose的CPU Rack去的話
是不是就會有可能會在AI的推論
或是工作的效率上面去造成一些折扣
稍微的跟業界的朋友
跟CSV的朋友請教一下之後發現說
其實他們是有做出一些
當然對我們那種做股票
或做投資來講有點複雜
簡單講就是說把一些工作去做切割
所以其實在一個SuperPod
或是一個AI Data Center裡面的運用
它是有可能
就是我多放幾台
可能General Purpose的伺服器
它就是可以透過一些
可能串聯的方式
或是說並聯的方式
然後就讓這個
General Purpose的Server
可以去幫忙卸載一些
可能在AI伺服器這邊的壓力
特別是在Agentic Wallflow裡面的運作
所以如果說可以看明白這點的話
然後去結合大家在供應鏈上所看到的一個狀態
就是目前CPU它算是在市場上一直被追加的東西GPU或是什麼HBM DRAM什麼這個非常缺大家都已經知道也不用再去多做討論CPU比較像是前面的一波蜂巢帶起來
然後後面大家開始去敲一些問號
因為想說你不是講說1比1
可是你們東西都沒有1比1
它那個1比1可能是這樣算的
就要把GP裡面的CPU全部加在一起
然後這樣去算的話
就想像成AI伺服器的量
大家都已經知道是差不多定量的
可能今天NVIDIA的REC就是一年可能5萬多
i4可能就7萬多
可是蠻多人沒有算到的是
general purpose的這些rack
或是這些trade
他們裡面有很多的CPU
有很多的intel或是amd的表現空間
前提是他們有secure到夠多的一個產能
所以在這樣的一個狀況之下
你把這些數字加起來
他就是有可能會讓
你就想像成說因為這邊衝得非常快
所以就會慢慢的去往1比1的方向去收容
只是他不會這麼快
就會慢慢的往這個方向去收容
所以看起來這個方向應該是可以做的
簡單來講
因為前面大家在說
KIMI的影響或什麼的
那我們就試著換個角度去
OK KIMI可能會造成一些影響
沒錯 雖然即便蠻多都被打臉了
但KIMI有沒有可能帶來某一些加速呢
在我們看來就是
他在推論的需求上面
或者Agenti AI的應用上
他會是一個加速
可能就是往這個方向去看
就是一個簡單的換句話說
有沒有可能我們找到一些機會
像最近市場上也有一個
新的鬼故事降臨
反正就是在講說在中國這邊
他們是有可能可以搞出自己的DUV
甚至是這樣
其實早在一兩年前
我們節目就有跟大家提到
他們有在試著去做自己的EUV
只是在我們的角度
或是說一些市場跟產業派的人
就會認為說
其實是超級困難的事情
簡單來講
就是以ASML來說
它也不是說一個國家
一家公司的一己之力
可以去做出它的DUV或是EUV
它是需要去協同各個國家的一些
頂尖科技才有辦法去做出來
其實在中國這邊
當然我們已經知道說
他們確實是有辦法用DUV
然後去做到很微小限寬的一個東西
就是透過重複曝光一些工序的方式去打倒
只是當然他犧牲的就是良率
他可能會花更多的成本
但他是有辦法土法煉鋼
去把一些東西搞出來
前陣子就是因為丟出來說
他們可能要去把DUV推出來
所以就造成可能像美股的設備的一些殺盤
美股設備殺盤之後
就影響到整個半導體又再一次的往下殺
這件事情的話就是一樣
就是我覺得一下市場很麻煩的點是
理論上是這樣
就是如果說有一個東西出來
它會對某些人造成傷害
它理論上會對一些人造成是加分的效果所以這時候如果你去看那些理論上造成加分的東西它有跟著上去的話你就可以解釋成為說市場可能真的在反映這件事情可是如果你發現說是一個通殺的局面的話
那不一定是這樣
就有點類似像它的盤
可能只是比較脆弱
所以任何的消息
都是有辦法把東西打下去
所以我們初不會這樣子看
因為它其實DUV的一個進程
在一些產業圈人士的角度
他們不會認為是一個新鮮事了
反正裡面就是有一些
北郭POYA去幫忙他們做
然後那種東西
其實已經是有一點雛形
然後持續在推薦
這個已經算是一個不爭的事實了
只是問題是在於說
今天你就算把你的DUV的東西做出來
其實要考量一點是
第一個是你的東西有沒有辦法出來
就是你有辦法去做出自己的一些曝光機
然後要去做生產
可是問題是你生產的東西外面不用的話
其實對外面的影響理論上是有限的
所以這邊的一個防線
它會是放在美國政府這一邊
如果說大家後來看到
美國政府真的開綠燈給蘋果
因為我們知道蘋果家
已經有一些新聞在報說
他們想要去遊說
要去使用CXMT的記憶體
其實在我們的角度
我們也是有聽說一些CSP
有在測他們的東西
只是問題是美國政府理論上
就是你那個關稅戰
貿易戰打成這個樣子
你不太可能會去放中國人一條深入
你已經是壓成這樣一個程度了
但如果說
他真的把這條大門打開的話
那可能就會出問題
我覺得他可能或多或少就可以解釋
市場家到底在恐慌什麼東西
因為中國的一個慣性就是我們知道
它可以非常便宜的去輸出大量的生產力
然後最後把整個市場搞到壞掉
不管是早先的記憶體
面板或是各種東西
其實要成熟自成
這個我們都知道說
就是中國人只要他有限要介入的話
其實他可以把超多東西玩到壞掉
所以如果說今天美國政府
並沒有去開這一扇門
讓蘋果或是讓這些CSP
可以去取得CXMT的記憶體的話
我就會認為說
它DUV這個事情的影響
應該是不會太大
因為你的東西是出不來的
但如果說今天是開了這個門
然後他又有一些生產的器具的話
那就會變得很麻煩
就他可以再一次的再搞傾銷的方式
然後把大家打到爆掉
所以這件事情就蠻像的
就如果說你考量美國政府的態度
假設雖然非常難以相信
但假設他真的最後面
開這條路給蘋果
或是說給那些CSP
你們可以用中國的一些料的話
那就可能或多或少可以解釋
這波到底在疊三小
所以就疊到後來
終於知道說有可能
再疊這個東西
但其實最後面搞不好
美國政府是非常嚴正的否決
那就不是跌那個
所以在下跌的時候
其實去做過多的找理由
好像意義也不是太大
但我們還是會想了解說
到底我們現在
它受到的傷害是什麼原因
所以還是會去稍微看一下
所以這邊簡單講一下這個事件就是
因為中國的東西現在都是被封禁的一個狀態
所以它做出來的東西
理論上也就是for它的內需的需求
你也知道說中國家對美貿易夥伴的一個名次
都已經調到台灣之後
就基本上台灣是已經取而代之了
中國做的東西就是內循環自己在做使用
所以他們就是自己在捲自己
甚至很多時候你會發現說
像中國自己的模型推出
就他們自己相關的模型常常抵要爛掉
反而是牆外的
美國都不一定得要爛掉
因為你可能你要中國的模型
你也不能用
就是他們可能有一些
內控或是說
政府的要求
一些東西是被封禁掉
你不能用
所以他們其實是自己在捲自己
以我現在的角度看
也會認為說
因為當他今天這個DUV出來
他一定就是直接送去CXMT
去做使用
所以也有可能就是
中國人自己在捲自己
只要美國這邊
不要去把這個大門打開
我覺得可能就影響有限
但是言歸正傳
就是現在盤面的狀態
真的不是太好
真的是回了非常的深
可是之所以一直沒有殺出一個
很大量的一個主因
就是可能就像一些大哥所提點的
因為你看那些股票
就算超多跌超深
跌到那種50%去的
他們其實也就是回到
四五月的一個價格而已
所以四五月可能到六月
是一個非常瘋狂的行情
然後現在大家再還
再還這一段
所以你沒有辦法看到一些
巨大的那種可能賣壓
或是超大的換手量出現的
原因可能在這
因為還蠻多人還沒有被殺到
只是當然這邊我們就會超級害怕
就是如果大家都抱持這個形態
反正我進來很久我就跟你耗
大家都一起耗的話
會不會就跌不完
希望不要發生
總之這是一個非常恐怖的行情
已經是可以載入實測了
我的鄰居還跑來問我說
那他前面跟我講說
這是不是大的場面
可能一兩個月前
我就說這根本不是什麼大場面
但他現在如果再跑來問我說
這是不是大場面
這個絕對是大場面
這個絕對是非常嚴重的一個暴力行情
總之就還是希望大家可以順利的度過
還是回歸到投資最核心的東西
簡單講就是說不要去做一些
能力範圍以外的事情
這個其實跟你的錢多少是沒有關係的
因為對每個人來講買滿都是100%
對一個10億的人來講買滿也是100%
1000萬的人100萬的人買滿都是100%
所以下去的時候
那股票在跌是用百分比去算的
其實我們後來發現這樣子
有蠻多那種大資
也是有可能在某一波的行情錯判
然後跟使用太大的槓桿
就一系回到解放前那種可能賺到幾億跑去當警衛的也是聽過幾次所以大家要小心我覺得在這樣的一個排名之下這樣不要去做超出自己能力範圍的東西如果說都是用現股去面對的話
特別是也不是剛加入市場
剛加入市場的其實就只能夠承擔
只能夠做這樣
因為每個都在跌
如果你今天是說
只有特定的一些東西在跌
那可能就是說你買到不好的東西
你的眼光有問題或什麼
可是當你發現全部人都在跌的時候
這個就是要試著承擔
市場可能有時候會有這樣的一些情形發生
希望後面可以盡快的好轉
這邊一個玄學小分享
後來發現什麼媽的我陽台的黃金格
可能是因為最近一直在那種戰鬥的角度
所以就沒有時間去顧到它
後來是幫我整理盆栽的一個老闆跟我講說
那個黃金格你要澆水
那個不是招財的東西嗎
怎麼現在要哭掉了
靠北趕快跑去澆水
所以澆了
希望後面你就是可以為我們代財
拜託不要再殺了
好 大家這樣
好 接下來我們今天Q的部分
第一位J.Cole Chan
到了今天才知道
原来红颜路比的上线是要叫大家这个暑假打电动就好的意思
这就是用心良苦吗
那想知道如果你在梦里可以选择女伴的话
你会选择Dualipop还是Taylor Swift
那另外想知道经历过这波的痛苦
你还会愿意陪Lisa去韩国吗
那最后想说
威威梦梦一起去日本
厉害的威梦让旅途顺畅无阻
有时候梦宝是怪怪宝
还好有威宝细心保护梦宝
好开始了
盘不好的时候就是你看
不是 微微夢夢是什麼鬼東西啊
再來前面講說可以選女伴的話
沒有 我一定是選我老婆啦
這兩個女的我是不可能會選她的
再來講說會不會再陪她去韓國
沒有 我老婆已經是歷事她不要再去韓國
就上次被Ajuma騙過之後她就是決定再來不要去
雖然我剛剛講說你知道她可以解除啦
就我們還是去嘛
其實韓國也沒有這麼差啊
有個降蟹啊或殺小的
但她就很生氣她被人家騙錢這件事情
下面一位
從今以後睡公園
安安夢宮進來安好
八月還要去玩嗎
還要去玩嗎
我現在人在大安森林公園的2330
軟弱無能區
這區蠻大的
但人也蠻多的
我先幫你卡一個位置
看要不要帶紙箱
不說了
連蚊子都不放過我
我先去借防蚊藝
這邊給大家一個很簡單的概念
但我發現其實很多人不知道
就是股票是一個相對的東西
所以要說你來市場裡面
就是你到廚房裡面
你就是一定會被燒到
被撿到被燙到
或什麼有的沒有的
所以如果你今天告訴大家
你滿守2330的話
其實在市場裡面的
各路的前輩或是大家會羨慕你
因為代表說你其實跌很少
因為2330真的跌很少
你怎麼不去問問我們這些媽手上還有一些中小的他真的很慘那種流動性被抽乾是超級恐怖的所以現在手握2330的市場的一個贏家也希望說2330後面會帶頭去做突破
但是也是有可能
因為2330家真的被太多人當盛虧股
當成是一個parking的地方
所以後面假設
雖然我們家已經是不抱太多的希望
假設中小一些熱門題材股
一些強勢股開指
就以前的強勢股
現在全部都媽跟垃圾一樣
就大家開始反彈的時候
有可能就是大家會從那邊撤出來
然後去買那些東西
所以就會變成說2330說不定
就是有可能在被提款的狀況之下
後面就不會這麼強
不一定都是要再看
可是以現階段
特別是以7月的year today來說的話
2330是絕對的最強的股票之一
所以你手上都是拿2330
應該只有拿什麼偽創跟偽引的可以贏你吧
其他人應該都是贏不過你
所以你其實不用去公園
你可以回家了
公園請讓給我們
下面一位
加MK好
想問平常用什麼軟體來記錄自己的期貨總部位跟獲利的狀況嗎
Percental失誤沒有辦法記錄期貨的樣子
另外想問MKH改有沒有裝空氣清淨機
台北的空氣真的好髒
開窗的話會有一堆灰塵
以下請唱歌
Because maybe
You gotta be the one that saves me
唱不下去了
我現在沒有心情
現在先不要叫我唱歌
我唱一唱可能會被人哭出來
再來
禁止的記錄的話
可以很簡單去拉個Excel就好
或是現在就直接丟給AI Agent
讓他幫你跑就好
就是不用再去用一些那種很土泡的方式
Presental這個APP我還是蠻喜歡用的
就是現股就用這邊去做記錄
但確實是期貨可能沒有辦法
所以期貨可以用一個
如果你要用這個APP的話
比較簡單的做法就是
你額外拉一個類似那種現金區
然後你就把期貨每天的禁止
直接自己手動提上去
這就是一個記錄的方式
下面一位大酒保公園
各位你好
我今年6月才進股市
我知道現在沙融之槓桿
但我全現股滿倉
全部都是0050成分股
目前負30幾%
我用明年的EPS來估都覺得很便宜
但他就是一直跌
我是不是被基本面綁架停損不下去
這位兄弟因為你是6月才加入
所以吃到回檔就叫做非常正常的事情
6月至今
就算你是什麼巴菲特還是什麼殺小的
叫你去買股票應該都是賠錢
因為就太難了
就基本上你買什麼都是賠錢
像是一個地域難度
確實像是一個非常高難度的盤
所以有時候就是這樣
就是因為你沒有辦法選擇你的出身
我覺得來說像
現在才要加入股票市場的人
他一定就是未来一两年
会被人家呈现的那些人
就像说像我自己在领口丢的一个生意那是我好朋友他就是去年的4月然后开始买他的第一筆股票他就覺得說股票是一個超級好的地方他根本不覺得股票是一個什麼會害人
會殺人的地方
就是怎麼買都是賺錢
所以真的會有這樣子的一些情形產生
所以你的出生點
其實會很高機率的決定了
你會變成是怎麼樣的一個個性
或是你對市場的看法是怎麼樣
這個在我們幾年前跟大家分享
Horamarks的一個memo的時候就有提到
為什麼Horamarks
他後來都會去做一些那種
distress company
或者是去做可能跟那種公司的債券
比較有關的一些東西
就是因為他當時進入市場的時候
他就看到當時的Nifty Fifty
你可以想像成現在的什麼M7之類
就大家都認為說
一定不會輸超級好的公司的爆炸
他就是看到那些爆炸
所以他對股票這種東西就覺得說
就像不知道他看到股票過來
就覺得說他一定是要亂摸屁股
他要強姦我直接趕快閃
他對股票會有一點
也不能說敵意
但就是會有很高的戒心
所以導致他選擇了那個路線
所以像這位兄弟
因為你加入的時間點
老實講是比較不幸運的
你剛好就是加入在AI的一個大回檔之際
你要知道這些AI的股票
其實從過去到現在
真的是為絕大多數
不管是台灣人 韓國人 日本人 美國人
都帶來非常巨量的報酬
所以對絕大多數人來講
這就是一個回檔
所以其實大家現在
如果你要去傳輸一些那種什麼
基本面的鬼故事
你可能也不一定嚇得到這些人
因為他們在過去看過太多個回檔
就類似我可能也看過很多個回檔
所以我就會覺得
就是OK 可能就是
某些理由導致它下跌
但我不會認為說是什麼
fundamental不行的
但因為按照你的角度是
你來的時候就是那個位置
所以你就會覺得說
是不是這些東西基本面不行
我只能夠說
你需要一點時間去適應一下
如果真的覺得不舒服的話
就去把部位降低
就不要打太滿
所以還是建議大家去參與投資的時候
先用小量去做嘗試
因為其實你不太確定
你會買在什麼樣的一個位置
但我覺得這是非戰之罪
這絕對不是說什麼你的問題
因為你跟我講
6月多你要選什麼股票
才可以避開這一波的下殺
超難 真的超級難
所以就只能夠稍微的去做承擔
只是說在後面
假設還想要再去買東西
要去做加碼
可以先慢慢等慢慢看
因為像我們節目前面分享的
其實像一堆東西
你看它已經跌到什麼
它在15倍的時候
我就開始在買它了
那它竟然可以變10倍股
類似這樣
我們不確定會不會後來
據來說反彈它是有出
真的有一個那種什麼絕世大跳
結果是發生在
它殺到變7倍股
其實從10倍變7倍又跌到30%
所以這個很難講
這個我們也沒有辦法去做一些預判
但確實如果你今天用一個
比較籠統的角度來說
前提是假設AI沒有爆炸
沒有什麼打抗泡沫
那種類似的事件出現的話
現在其實真的蠻多東西
是在所謂的便宜的地方
過去可能
我們跟大家講一些股票的時候說
現在這個股票貴
其實現在都在推估值什麼的
現在回頭看就覺得說好好笑
就是一瞬間從那樣的一個情景變成
哇 滿地都是便宜貨
現在情況是這樣子
所以你覺得它便宜是正常的
只是便宜不代表它就不會再更便宜
特別是你現在回頭看
可能像是2022年的台積電300多塊
你應該也覺得不可思議
其實那時候的600多塊
就已經不是一個很貴的股票
就是它一樣殺到300多塊
然後後來它變成一個2000多塊的東西
只是你還有辦法活著
看到它變2000多塊那一天
下面一位
巨型龜頭
夢攻995
跌到現在早上起床都不會沉伯了
每天起床都像是在背鋼
不對背鋼可能還比較舒服
勞工可以救救台股
救救愛普嗎
大盤今天這樣算跌不跌出量
那雖然也才1.08兆
還有韓國人都可以去紅幹嗎
都去跳樓跳一跳好了
不要這樣
現在大家都是一起痛苦的
有韓國人的地方真的都沒有好事
可以開始抵制韓國了
另外祝福台灣的大家
明天庫存都漲停
陳寧吉言
希望大家明天
不然你至少給個人道走讓大家喘一下
讓大家調一下部位
我覺得是真的蠻需要
得到這個位置
其實出個反彈是還算合理的
再來講說這個算不算出量還好
認真說還好
就呼應到我們前面所提到的
可能真的太多人的成本在很低的地方
所以現在其實就是一個那種
你得到的東西你失去的痛苦
但是你沒有到
就是覺得說像前面的幾波回檔
像那個2024年7月
鴻海為首的那個ODM大回檔
是很多人直接把全年獲利輸光
而且他不是可能在高檔才加入的
他只是因為行情太瘋狂
然後疊成價物上去
後來一波倒下
就一直罵一整年都輸光
今年我還比較少聽到
就是我們身邊的
然後有全年輸光的
幾乎比較嚴重的大概回到三四月
比較不嚴重的
就是平常會扣現金
大概回到六月左右
像我自己是回到五月
要往五月初的方向去
所以可能就是因為這樣才沒有出量
因為我們在猜說
奇怪為什麼都不會出量
到底是嗎 殺小
其實已經有很多東西開始在斷頭了
只是就真的都沒有爆量
可能原子在之後
就像過往大家很喜歡那個
邀遲金木981A
它的很多成分股價
大家笑它什麼埋在山頂
沒有 其實你去認真看
它有買多東西
它都還是賺錢的 非常扯
它其實它很早就開始在買了
只是過去買山頂的很痛
然後對它來講就是一個回吐
所以它甚至
它為什麼沒有去處分那些東西的原因
是因為它就覺得說
它都還是賺錢的
所以它搞不好甚至還要去加碼
所以你如果站在這樣的角度去看就是今年因為真的噴太多了其實你看貴買蝦疊成這樣它只是疊回去那時候是什麼親密連假就親密連假之後的起場點
所以很恐怖
我希望下面不要再太深了
因為其實按照下的角度看
真的買的東西已經到便宜了
再往下真的就是讓我老闆不在家了
下面一位
困寶明天是我的生日
可以跟我說說幾句話嗎
挂號跟羅志祥
妥中康同一天生日的26歲澎湖男子
希望你远离股票
要小心股票
股票是很恐怖的东西
下面一位
好了 生日快乐还是要讲
唱诗班不唱诗在班砖头中
诸位武安上次来留言
怕爆天罚要来了
感谢梦工大
让我现在还可以开心的
和我兄弟班砖头中
当李砖跟我说
还有子弹可以在家
我只能够回他
如果我有子弹
我就打爆你的头
希望大家都能够捏紧扛过这一波
最后请用川普的余韻包
祝我美丽的老婆
生日快樂要每天開心
現在語音包也講不出來了
現在就是處在一個在反省自己
深刻的去檢討
為什麼前面貪便宜買這麼快
買到現在其實有點
其實也不知道後面該怎麼辦的一個境界
還是穿補一下
What a great woman this is
Nobody knows birthday better than I do
好啦 希望她可以生日快樂、平安、健康
下面一位 龜頭跳蛋
一個月前我抱著死了算了的心情
all in正二
現在彷彿站在頂頭看著地面的大家
我以為我的心態是真的捨算的
結果當這天來臨時還是會怕高
對啦
就是如果說你真的是在過去的
6 7月才加入的
其實真的不要對自己有太多的苛責
這就有點類似說
那時候其實也蠻多人是在2021
那種最頂峰的時候才加入
2020你看他加入直接跌一整年
那個也是極度的痛苦
他就會覺得說股票就是騙人的東西
可是你問其他參與夠久
就會知道說
這股票其實它是不錯的東西
像我們前面講的那些都是在跟人家開玩笑的
就是實際上它是不錯
只是你要有那一個
Guts
你要有那一個膽識可以扛住
隨之而來的一些波動或什麼的
所以很多時候我都講說
奇怪了
每次都不會有人在
像這時候你來問我
可不可以全職交易
我就會覺得說
這個是一條漢子
都不會
都是在那種極好
就是Monkey都會賺錢的時候
然後拼命問
然後像這種時候就大家都拼命都不要了
所以真的是玩人性的地方
下面一位大人
昨天看到統神玩紅顏路比真的太搞笑了
我要去買新電腦來玩的
對啦我前面講的實況主就在講他
我不好意思去點名人家因為還是非常感謝人家支持只是他媽的為什麼他會玩得很痛苦的原因是因為他就不知道要右鍵按著然後接著去疊成閃召之後再配Shift
他給我從頭到尾都平A
然後我們群組一直在觀察他
說怎樣 幹他媽的十里坡戰神
第一次看到有人玩紅眼路比打王平A
然後還真的就給他打過去
然後他就一直狂罵說
不知道這遊戲還幹三角
不是啊 兄弟
不是啊 教學要看一下
真的這樣
下面一位
賺錢治古矮
孟光安不知道你的心情还好吗
7月前两周
我的获利回吐很多
导致情绪低落
又不想把压力带给身边的人
无处抒发感觉有点窒息
因为你的节目陪伴
才有不孤单的感觉
后来检讨出许多可以改进的地方
心中踏实不少
想到孟光在面对压力的同时
还要接触到群众的负面情绪
不禁自作主张的替您感到心疼
希望您也可以保持身心健康愉快
讲完都觉得自己有点假了
但还是爱您
非常感谢这位兄弟的支持
那確實對我來講這已經不是什麼新鮮事情了
所以其實我才會想要把這個節目
就是可能調整成為
未來有一天
就是我們可能就專注去聊QA
因為這個節目對我來說還是有它的價值存在
就是像我每次去跟大家問說
其實講白講我會拋磚引玉
我想知道可能隨便舉例Google
或是Marvel的某一顆晶片或什麼
我就稍微提一下
然後接著就一定會有聽眾來跟我講
所以有點說我在釣魚
那對我來講這其實超級有用的
因為在我工作上面會有非常大的一個
只是變成說因為我要維持這樣的一個節奏
就是要跟大家聊市場的東西
才要引起一些共鳴嘛
可是聊市場的東西
然後特別在行情很好的時候
就會引來一群比較不喜歡的對象了
就我也不會想去罵這些人了
因為有時候你也覺得人家蠻可憐的
但就會這樣子
所以其實像前面行情很好的時候
有些新的聽眾可能會不懂說
為什麼那時候我會一直有點
就是明明行情很好
可是我在那種一堆人勇促的狀況之下
大家講說什麼你去逛每個社群面
每個人都愛什麼古來說
古來說夢宮說
然後我在那時候說
他媽我最怕這種人
因為2021我看過一次
就一樣的道理
因為我就知道
我就知道說就是這些人
他們後面就會變成是
反正他當時怎麼愛你
他後來就怎麼恨你
那你不想要這種廉價的關係
其實對我來想
我現在想要的是就來說
你知道我在做紅顏路比
你會來支持紅顏路比的這樣的人
或是你知道說
我今天在研究什麼故事
你會來跟我分享 跟我討論
其實我真的在入圖中
我找到非常多這樣子的聽眾
非常感謝大家支持
只是當然一定會引來一些
我可能比較不喜歡的受眾沒有辦法可能就只能夠去接受它這樣子希望望自己有照一日也可以釋懷這件事情那非常感謝你的支持也希望你可以其實簡單來講說在每次的修正之後
理論上你沒有倒下
你就會變更加強大
因為你看過你知道
所以像前面講說在去年3月
其實有些投資公司就因為這樣就出事了
有時候覺得蠻可惜的
因為有些可能你認識裡面的一些人之類的
然後你就知道說假設他那坡活下來
他現在一定會變更屌
可是他沒有活下來
所以為什麼我們一直去跟大家強調說
風險絕對是放在獲利的前面
你在大多頭的時候大家跟我說
你為什麼不要借報
為什麼不要港報
為什麼不要什麼
你就O-In 真額
或是你就買什麼就好
但你覺得做到回檔
就不會再有一些人去講這些東西
因為你就掛了
你就掛了
你就沒有辦法再面對後面的東西
所以其實每次的回檔
真的是好好的去檢討自己策略
很棒的一個時間點
希望大家都可以持續的變強
那下面一位999
梦宮騎腳踏車你會不會喜歡
最近有個朋友高中畢業之後
沒有騎過腳踏車
只是騎了一小段U-bike
他說是他近期覺得最放鬆的時候
這個我也非常推薦
就是蠻推薦大家
如果你已經很久沒有騎腳踏車的話
你去租一個U-bike
然後你選擇5點半6點
太陽剛下山
開始有一點微風
兩天的時候你去騎腳踏車
你真的是超級俗壓
特別是你很久沒有騎
你會突然間有很多那種小時候的回憶跑上來
像我有時候陪小孩子去騎一下
那真的是一個蠻不錯的運動
那下面一位
Will C
夢宮去趕安安
想問夢宮一開始有跟Lisa遠距離過嗎
小弟剛畢業研究生
生活混沌
毫無章法可言
女友外國人感覺常常被我氣到
又要開啟安撫SOP
遠距離到底平常都該注意什麼
好難啊
最後希望夢工用猛男的聲音助各路
英雄們吃飲保態安全第一
打魂系遊戲最怕貪刀了愛妮
這個說得真好
其實現在就是一個很怕貪刀的時間點
就來說像前幾天不是有某一檔記憶體去漲停嗎
如果說你看他轉牆然後你又衝進去了
你貪刀你又被幹了
所以我現在真的是很怕那一種
就是還在那邊很強的
我反而覺得說你那種早早掉下來的
我會想選
所以這跟我的邏輯平常是相反
平常我會選
就是相對形態還好的
可是我現在就發現說
這部行情片你選形態還好的
你就是後面會被教訓的更重而已
所以真的是不要貪刀
那可能回歸到投資的基本
哪些公司是你真的喜歡的
你研究你有convision
你知道他後面的發展不錯
你至少你抱著這些東西
你心裡也比較安定一點
那就是小亮的去做磁場
可能知道這樣子
那再來是不是有遠距離過
有一小段時間
因為那時候我老婆她剛來
然後她又要回去
他沒有立即都決定要搬來台灣
可是只要一進入遠距離的狀態
他就開始會整天猜忌說我在幹嘛或什麼的
那他後來其實也知道說
就是我晚上可能
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕